"This is what we're going to do now.
We are going to Valencia, so this is what
this episode is about."
"The best way to get to know Valencia is by
bike.
We found a rental in the center and started
our exploration right away."
"So we've come to the Mercado Central..."
... to start our discovery of Valencia."
"Hmm, Greg is in Heaven right now."
"Jamones."
"We've come to the heart of the city.
It's Plaza de la Reina and la Catedral."
"So we've come to the Horchateria Santa Catalina
to try horchata, which is a typical Valencia drink.
It's so sweet."
"The next one on our list is the Jardines
del Turia which used to be a river, but is
now a giant park."
"Where people run, ride bikes, work out, whatever."
"And it runs all the way down from the city
to the coast."
"To the beach."
"And this is where we are going next."
"After half an hour of cycling, we've made
it to Playa de las Serena which is a really
white beach here in Valencia.
A good spot to hang out and get some sun."
"When in Valencia, of course you need to eat
..."
"...the typical paella."
"So the last one on our list is la Ciudad de
las Artes."
"And this is where we are going to watch the
sun set."
"That's it from Valencia.
Hasta luego."